hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast and i'm
just checking in
on you
what's going on
how are you
um
oh
do i have a story to tell you
oh do i have a story to tell you hang on
a second are you leaving yeah
oh
all right bye
bye
[Music]
all right
i'll see you later sorry
dad's going on the road
on the road again
boom boom going up to [ __ ] sac town
again
we're just friends
well i'm doing i'm doing a podcast
i don't want to give the pat back i was
supposed to give you a hug and all this
before you started yeah but you didn't
all right bye bye
doing a podcast all right see you later
look good nene thank you
all right um
so
oh freckles what does he do what does he
do i [ __ ]
all right i'll tell you what happened
a few weeks ago and then you'll guess
when i'm about ready to tell you so i
[ __ ] finally got my car fixed
all right
my beautiful son closed the frigging
gate on it
as i was backing out
you know all of a sudden i just heard
the gate hit my car i'm like how the
hell did i hit the gate i've never hit
the gate in my life i looked it wasn't
there and then i looked up and my son
was just pressing down on the remote
control with like every fiber of his
being it was hilarious with this crazy
look on his face
as toddlers do when they're trying to
you know
do something that requires a little bit
of effort right so
all right
so it [ __ ] up my door in my side view
mirror or whatever and i was shooting
the movie
so my car's [ __ ] up the entire time
i'm doing the movie and i'm one of those
guys some people get a dent in their car
and they don't ever get it fixed
i'm not one of those people i go down i
get it [ __ ] fixed
i'm not riding around in a goddamn
jalopy i never understood why parents
just let their cars
go to [ __ ]
you
know and look if you don't have the
[ __ ] money to fix it i get that but
when you have the money to fix it you
just content to drive around with a big
[ __ ] dent in the side of your car i
just think it says something about you
you know
did you know you're there to do the job
but
you don't quite do it great you're all
right with it
as long as it kind of gets done
i don't like it you know what i mean
it's like someone who wears a short
sleeve dress shirt underneath uh a sport
coat
and you're looking at their wrists
you know when they go to reach for
something instead of this shirt there's
just there's a sloppiness to it
all right and i think it reflects on how
people people see you the way you
present yourself so anyway i get my
finally get my car fixed i'm [ __ ]
psyched
i got it back two weeks ago last night
i go down
to the avalon
drive all the way over there right it's
a premiere for the george carlin
documentary done by the
incredible mike bonfiglio
and um they're having a premiere for it
it's old freckles
you know ran is yapping that doc for a
little bit
they asked me to come down to premiere
and i said absolutely it's george carlin
no him
no no no me
he's on the mount rushmore of course i'm
going to go down there so i go down
there
my beautiful car with no dents
nice clear wrap on it to to save the
paint
i [ __ ] go over i do the red carpet
you know answering all the questions
standing there doing the [ __ ] step
and repeat the whole thing
then all of a sudden this guy comes up
to me goes hey you drive the blah blah
blah and i said yeah he said oh man he
got
i go why
he goes somebody just backed into it i
go you got to be [ __ ] kidding me
you got to be [ __ ] kidding me i just
got the [ __ ] thing fixed
and i'm going over there you got you
[ __ ] got to be and i walk over i'm
looking at the doors everything's fine
he goes no it's on the front
and i go around the front there's all
this white [ __ ]
streak mark on the front and he got the
[ __ ]
the cover to the front light [ __ ] that
up too
right
and then this guy gets out nice enough
person
right
dressed like [ __ ] clark kent
sport coat and everything goes oh sorry
i'm like whatever
because i was backing in i just want to
be like how the [ __ ] did you hit it
how the [ __ ] did you hit my car this
back up cameras in cars and they got the
[ __ ] sensor that beeps
beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep
stop you [ __ ] [ __ ] and he still
backs into my [ __ ] car
[ __ ] talking what the [ __ ] were you
doing i just feel like look
i don't want to [ __ ] do this so i
just like all right whatever he goes you
want to exchange papers it's like i
don't want to continue this relationship
i've known you for [ __ ] eight seconds
and you backed into my car why do i want
to know who you are
i'm like no forget it he was like girls
gonna say i'm a big fan of your comedy
ah
i'm sure he's a nice enough guy but that
[ __ ] guy if you're listening you
[ __ ] suck at driving and there is no
excuse for that
you have a [ __ ] backup camera and
it's not like he just dinged it he
[ __ ] banged into it
i don't know i just i don't [ __ ] do i
i i don't i don't like
i have to tell you it is better because
back in the day when i first moved out
here and i had my prius
i couldn't keep the bumpers
looking nice every time i get them fixed
like [ __ ] within a week somebody
would would bump into them you know
parking or whatever but since then since
the backup cameras like that shit's not
supposed to happen it's supposed to be
fail safe
so whatever
whatever he did say let's exchange
papers but i i'd never do that
it's like i don't want to get involved
in all of that then my person has to
call your person and then your person
says this and then my person says that
and then everybody has to circle back
and then talk it's just like just [ __ ]
it
[ __ ] it i'll go down there
i'll go down to those those sons of
[ __ ] that fix my [ __ ] car
and you know and they tell me what it's
going to be and then i go down there
with the credit card and they say no my
friend you said it was going to be cash
and i said no i didn't and they said my
friend this is what we have down here
first of all we're not friends
we're not friends you're what we're
friends because you fixed my car
you know this isn't mad max you know
we're in the middle of the desert then
then we could do that [ __ ] bro
handshake or instead of shaking hands we
[ __ ] grab each other's forearms all
right but as long as society is still
working and people still believe in the
dollar you just provided a service so
we're not friends
okay my friend
anyway i love when you go to those
places and they only want cash don't you
always immediately just feel like you're
looking over your shoulder like
somebody's gonna come run in here and
try to rob this place
you know like the other day
we'll call it last night
we stopped off at the weed store you
know i'm not a big weed guy but you know
occasionally i partake
i don't like smoking it's weird i'll
smoke a cigar but i don't like taking it
into my lungs coughing my [ __ ] brains
out so i'm a gummy you know little five
i [ __ ] you know
take one i could sit there and deal with
you know
the real housewives but i don't like
doing it
a lot because when i do it then i just
start doing it every night and then it
just you know gets out of control so i
just
you know i have one of those every once
in a while so last night wasn't every
once in a while right
and um
you know we go into the [ __ ] weed
story and i tell you it still blows my
[ __ ] mind that you can walk in there
and there's just all of this weed out in
the open like this [ __ ] was illegal
for the first 50 years of my life or
whatever i just it's insane to me
and but
i've noticed when you go into those weed
stores it's just like a liquor store
where there's always that feeling
whenever i'm in a liquor store back in
the day when i drank whenever i go to
liquor store there would always be this
feeling
especially at night than any and i had
to do the transaction and get the [ __ ]
out of there because at any second
someone was coming in a ski mask and was
going to rob it i don't like going into
businesses that are just cash
you know and i don't like the weed store
too because they [ __ ] scan your
driver's license it's like what the [ __ ]
are we doing here
yeah the guy wanted to scan my license
last night i'm like i'm not buying
anything he was cool though he's like
all right they usually like oh
[ __ ] store uh i know everything about
you uh it's like why do you have to scan
my driver's license
like what what is that
what is that for
you know what i mean who do you what is
that that what do they call that uh
revenue stream where do you sell that to
who do you have to [ __ ] report to the
shit's legal it's [ __ ] legal but not
at a federal level
right what are they gonna come back and
uh
prosecute us after texas makes weed
illegal
after they roll that back
oh no fun texas you know you can't go
down there
[ __ ] some chicken your goddamn cowboy
boots and hat bust the nutner and then
get a do-over can't do that in texas
anymore no fun in texas
i'll tell you right now
if you're not paying state taxes you're
gonna keep your baby you had with that
that [ __ ] woman from the waffle house
um
one of the dumbest things in the history
of the [ __ ] world is they're gonna
roll back roe v wade and when there's
over seven billion people on the [ __ ]
planet
and the whole ocean is full of plastic
to the point i don't even eat fish
anymore everybody's testing positive for
plastic you're [ __ ] literally
eating the [ __ ] that you didn't need and
you ended up throwing up
i mean that should be a story on the
news every [ __ ] night of how we're
gonna clean that up
it should be a story in the news every
night about how a select group of
[ __ ] greedy [ __ ] turned our entire
food supply into poison and now they're
trying to force it on the rest of the
world
that should be stories nope that's not a
[ __ ] story
that's not a story they'd rather focus
on [ __ ] stand-up comedy
you know or or talk about the russians
and act like you know
when they invade a country they don't do
it the right way but when others wink
wink nudge nudged invade a country we do
it the right way and no innocent people
die [ __ ] out of here
oh i'm in a mood
why bill because you care about society
or because some [ __ ] four-eyed [ __ ]
backed into your [ __ ] car despite
having every piece of technology to not
make that happen
you know you know that thing that your
parents used to say just can't have
anything nice
we just can't have anything nice
that's what i feel like right now
um
whatever i'll get the car fixed
and i'll forget about it
um i just know when i go back to my
friends my friend my friend they're
gonna think that i did it and i'd be
like i didn't do it and then i'll be
like okay my friend my friend it's okay
did you not have the sensor turned on
you know i could put on a a better
center my friend my friend
all right is it okay if i use my credit
card of course my friend
ten days later when it's done okay you
said cash
no my friend we said oh you know you pay
the card it's going to be more money my
friend
um
i love my friend because nobody says
that
you know it's not like you uh
you know
you go to france bonjour they actually
say that
i just love how a a group of people
comes over here and they latch on to
[ __ ] that is english
and they and they create these
expressions that nobody [ __ ] uses
like paul verzi created
you know
end of the day you got to find out what
that dog has in his what is it you got
to see what that dog has in its [ __ ]
mouth
and i am determined to turn that into an
expression
my friend
oh where do i go from here red sox hit a
grand slam
a couple nights back right
rafi deiver
hit a grand slam we got the bats going
everything
everything's looking great
[ __ ] last night
i'm watching the red sox
trevor story trevor
finally gets his first [ __ ] home run
two run [ __ ] shot dude i think we had
a single and he hits a two run shot to
[ __ ] left field or left center or
something like that
then we get a double
uh
we get a single
score a run the guy in the throw the
plate goes to second base they end the
ending we're up three to nothing
ivaldi's [ __ ] killing it
basically throwing a perfect game
through like you know three innings and
then
fourth inning lets up a single on a
quick pitch and then the very next one
guy hits a two run [ __ ] shot
then he lets up back to back doubles
then it's [ __ ] three to three and
here we are again and here we are again
we end up losing the game six to three i
can't remember the last time we won two
games in a row
and i was really hoping that all of a
sudden we were going to turn it around
uh we can still win this series but
jesus christ
what is our record we're like 10 and 19
or something
let's see what do we got here the
standings here they are
i'm enjoying these standings despite the
fact that we are in last place we're two
games behind the baltimore orioles we're
playing
355 ball we're 11 and 20.
all right
and as much as i can't stand
i can't stand that the yankees are in
first place 22 and eight just tearing
through the league what i do enjoy
most about looking at the american
league east
is the toronto blue jays
oh look at them all they're [ __ ]
yapping
last year was the trailer this year's
the movie and they came out like
gangbusters but they were playing the
red sox so we suck
so far this year
they were playing the orioles
all of a sudden they came started
playing some teams that are going to
compete where are they now 17 and 15.
531 went three and seven on their last
ten there you go right in the middle of
the pack
right where you belong i don't root for
the toronto blue jays
i'm not gonna lie to you i did enjoy
that they were talking [ __ ]
it did make it fun um but i actually uh
i'm a maple leaf fan
let's see how they're doing in their
series last i saw
they were up two games to one come on
maple leafs win a series they're up
three games to two
against the defending back-to-back
stanley cup champions the ones who stole
their colors
the tampa bay lightning
are to the toronto maple leafs what the
pittsburgh penguins are to the boston
bruins they're a team that came after
that came in and just took colors that
were already taken they didn't even like
change the blue it's almost like the
same blue same thing with the penguins
with this dumb black and gold
you know
and then their argument was like well we
originally had black and gold with our
first [ __ ] team uh yeah but it didn't
make it through the depression and then
the bruins came along and they had those
colors for like [ __ ] 40 years you
[ __ ]
um
anyway
i'm rooting for the toronto maples my
boston celtics lost
and we are in this situation i didn't
want to be him
okay because i knew at some point we
were gonna have to beat the milwaukee
bucks two games in a row and i said to
my buddy i says to the guy i says
if we're gonna do it we have to we have
to win
game five so we would won game four in
game five and then split six and seven i
don't see the milwaukee bucks losing
game six and game seven
i see us winning game six but we gotta
do it in their [ __ ] building oh man
i don't know but the celtics have a lot
of hat
so i think that we can do it but uh
we had that game where we just sort of
let it slip away in the fourth quarter
and i gotta tell you
by the way man i knew
you know
giannis giannis antetokounmpo was
[ __ ] amazing but something about this
series just watching him play with when
other guys are hurt
when he puts the team on his back or
whatever i mean the guy's got his first
step as fast as is as fast as a lot of
the point guards in the league and the
guy's [ __ ] unbelievable
um
not gonna lie to you actually like that
team
and i love that city so
and then the bruins also lose the bruins
after going down 0-2
came back won the next two in boston and
then lose
pretty soundly down in
carolina i will say the thing that's
been like depressing is that you know
the games that carolina uh
has won they just look like just head
and shoulders a better team than we are
so but i'm not giving them up giving up
on them because
because we have the perfection line man
and i've seen them come back time and
time again so
all we got to do is win the next one and
then it's anybody's [ __ ] game and
that's what the situation the celtics
are in so i'm gonna age like 400 years
over the next like four days as i watch
these [ __ ] games six and seven well
not four days up nba will probably drag
it out to seven days
um but other than that
uh oh billy [ __ ] red face is gonna be
uh
up in sacramento oakland and fresno
and you know what that means that means
quick flights
it's gonna be a good time um i feel like
i haven't been up there since the
pandemic so i'm kind of excited to go up
there i used to always do the punch line
in sacramento there was never a gig in
oakland i used to always do um
at least for a white guy
i used to do um
the punch line in san francisco
and then fresno
um
i haven't done fresno in a couple years
fresno is always fun
uh
so i'm looking forward to that and with
that let's read a little bit of the uh
some advertising here people by the way
if you have a backup camera and you have
the sensor just you know go you'll go on
youtube and learn how to use it
what does it mean when the beeps get
faster what does it mean when the beeps
going beep
what does that mean
[ __ ] idiot
all right simply safe
you guys know i love the break-in
protection that my simply safe home
security system gives me but it's not
always outside forces that you need
simply
saves protection from this is joshua's
story
a simply safe customer from indiana a
few months ago he fell asleep with pizza
rolls still in the oven
oh this guy this guy definitely hit the
weed store
uh this could have been disastrous
thousands of dollars in damage to his
kitchen and home or worse luckily joshua
has a comprehensive simply safe system
equipped with everything to prevent
break-ins
and smoke detectors to snip off sniff
out fires i mean that's huge
he startled awake to the sound of a 95
decibel alarm from his simply safe base
station seconds later he got a call from
simply safe professional monitoring
the pizza rolls didn't make it but
joshua did
that's funny they call you up is there a
fire yeah i'm trying to put it out he
believes simply safe probably saved his
life that night do you have time to take
a survey once again i'm trying to put
out a f protecting people when their
guard is down is just one of the reasons
more than 4 million people using love
simply safe i mean this is it right here
guys i mean you you don't want some
creep coming into your house you don't
want to [ __ ] die of smoke
uh in into inhalation
is that is it intervention and you know
uh you don't want to burn to death
wouldn't it be great if you could
[ __ ] get something like that to
protect you from that for under a dollar
a day
well with the comprehensive simply safe
system and 24 7 professional monitoring
you always have someone looking out for
you plants cost under a dollar a day
with no long-term contracts or hidden
fees ever you can customize the perfect
system for your home
in just a few minutes at
simplysafe.com go today and claim a free
indoor security camera plus twenty
percent off with interactive monitoring
go to simplysafe.com
that's s-i-m-p-l-i-s-a-f-e
dot com slash burr all right oh look who
it is everybody
it's solo stove
uh there's nothing quite like the
feeling of gathering around a warm fire
on a cool evening and a smokeless fire
pit from solo stove makes your outdoor
moments even more memorable because
instead of having to customize
constantly dodge campfire fumes you can
sit back relax and actually enjoy the
fire
and right now you can get a great deal
on a solo stove fire pit upgrade your
backyard with the solo stove fire pit
it's the perfect catalyst for getting
outside and spending more time with
family and friends solo stove fire pits
are brilliantly engineered made with
premium grade 304 stainless steel 304
people not that 303 [ __ ] and a 360
degree airflow system that maximizes
efficiency while minimizing smoke
basically it's clean it's sleek it's
portable
you get all the wonder
wonderful um advantage of a nice warm
fire without the smoke it's the perfect
outdoor
campfire easy to light with a few bits
of starter your fire is blazing in
minutes minutes perfectly portable shop
now and get 30 off fire pits all month
long and use the promo code bur b-u-r-r
at checkout to get an extra ten dollars
off plus a lifetime warranty and free
30-day returns just go to solo stove
solostove.com
s-o-l-o-s-t-o-v-e let's see if that
works s-o-l-o-s-t-o-v
damn it it didn't work
and remember you get 10 off when you use
the promo code bur
all right lastly but certainly not
leastly because everybody has a story to
tell in advertising all birds everyone
all birds created
create shoes and clothing that are
better for you and better for the planet
using a revolutionary roster of premium
natural materials like their popular
tree runner sneaker why is it called the
tree runner you ask because it's made
from eucalyptus tree fiber a lightweight
breathable and silky soft material
making the tree running the perfect
everyday shoe for the uh for getting the
most out of sunny days made with premium
natural materials like eucalyptus fiber
this is great someday for when your
sneaker ends up in the friggin ocean you
know the fact that it's mostly made out
of a tree
uh designed with a breath with a
breathable knit that keeps your feet
cool while you're soaking up the sun and
they're super lightweight making them
the perfect pair to take along on any
adventure uh and god bless this country
uh country god bless this company for
actually taking the time to give a [ __ ]
about the environment uh i'm feeling
like young people's companies more and
more are going to be like this
showing us old people what we were doing
wrong and i am all for it uh minimal and
versatile for effortless everyday style
thoughtfully designed without any
unnecessary frills or logos to go with
every outfit find your new favorite
shoes for sunny days and upcoming travel
at allbirds.com that's a l l
b i r d s dot com
all right
so anyway
um it really blows my mind that they're
gonna roll but i understand people that
that you know think that uh abortion is
killing a baby i mean
i mean yeah that totally makes sense to
me but you know you got to kill some
right
we have too many [ __ ] people
um jesus clearly isn't coming back
he's not coming back the guy the guy
we're sitting here like a bunch of
[ __ ]
ladies on a widow walk every night
looking out to see wait for this guy to
come back he's he's not coming back he
wouldn't come back
like this this there's that theory with
religious people that when we finally
just do that final awful thing to one
another that he's gonna show up and it's
just like okay
there's been slavery holocaust human
trafficking
invasions of countries
kids getting killed schools bombed and
all that he's yet to make an appearance
so my question
is what the [ __ ] he waiting for
i don't think he's coming back
you know
any more than i think he was actually
the son of god
or a white person i'm [ __ ] with you
um
yeah at some point guys i don't i don't
what are we doing here i mean i don't
have the solutions
it's not going to stop me from talking
about it though right
sorry i just realized i think i caught
my son's cold
god damn it right before this oh billy
nasal knows
um
by the way one of the places i'm playing
i think on this one is uh the cow palace
and the cow palace is like
whenever i used to hear about van halen
starting out and all the bands i liked
at some point they all played the cow
palace
so i got dean del rey on the show which
is cool because he went to a zillion
concerts there we're gonna have a
[ __ ] great time
um i have edited together some
drum video clips of when i was playing
in the forum before the show just to
hear uh
just for you guys to hear how good that
further drums here how good the sound is
i know i suck i don't need to [ __ ]
listen to it i know my foot was sloppy i
hadn't played in a couple of months
because i had the acting gig all right
and not only that i'm not a pro drummer
and i'm a [ __ ] dad so you know
take it with a grain of salt but i i
i had a [ __ ] blast doing it and um
you know if i had the time and the
[ __ ] and all of that that's
something i would i would do
in every one of these [ __ ] arenas
because it was that much fun uh maybe
not on this one maybe on the next one
because who knows who knows you know do
i ever get to do this [ __ ] again i don't
know
hopefully i do but if i don't i can say
you know what i got all of it he got all
of that one
all right well that's the podcast here
for thursday thank you guys so much for
listening um i forgive that [ __ ]
clark kent bastard for backing into my
car
trying to anyway um my intermittent
fasting seems to be working
i'm i still have a nice [ __ ] pooch
covered pooch
to see pooch is that an omicron a delta
or a coveted 19 pooch i know kind of all
three an amalgam
sort of like a smorgasbord
of ice cream sandwiches late at night
wondering if the world was ever going to
come back
um
all right
no more abortions
no more abortions no vaccines breathe on
the babies that's how we'll kill them
maybe that's how they do it don't
vaccinate me
i'll breathe on the baby that way nobody
killed the baby and it's more like uh
the bat did it all right i get it now
you know what i want to apologize to
texas i think you guys actually
understand what's going on
i'm going to tell you right now
if that's implemented or when it's
implemented i guarantee you there's
going to be a lot of shiny four-door
pickup trucks
driving across the border into arkansas
um or wherever the [ __ ] abortions are
legal um all right that's it everybody
uh enjoy the music in the bonus episode
of the thursday afternoon just before
friday monday morning podcasts from a
year ago or however andrew thomas
figures it out okay see
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday may 13th
2013. how are you
how's it going
uh-oh may 13 2013.
a lot of 13s are you superstitious do
you think 13 is an unlucky number let me
ask you this why
why do you think it's unlucky
because you were told that
from the day you were born
you know stay away from that 13. it's a
[ __ ] bad egg really
yeah it's a it's a number
you know about 13 you can't get to 14.
you know you raise how [ __ ] childish
that is
like all these hotels
where they they they called the 13th
floor of the 14th floor
you know it's like dude we're on the
13th floor i don't give a [ __ ] what you
call it
you start calling an apple in orange i
bite into it it's still a [ __ ] apple
you know i i don't understand like
the thing that i will never get past
is how [ __ ] childish adults are that
you know these hot these [ __ ] hotels
had to not have a 13th floor because
there's so many [ __ ] people that
believe in that horseshit that they
literally will they won't i don't want
to stay on the 13th floor why because
you're worried the 14th floor is going
to collapse onto it
you stupid [ __ ]
you know and you know what kills me
no bill what kills you well i'll tell
you god damn it what kills me is how
because of the dollar these [ __ ]
people think they they
pander to him
dude i want to get a room in the hotel
okay we got 1306
i can't stay on the 13th floor i i can't
stay i need another floor 13's unlucky
and what do they do they give them
another floor
you know
right there they should be like well
listen why don't you [ __ ] grow up
what do you think we use a less grade of
quality concrete when we made that floor
you [ __ ]
you know what [ __ ] you we don't want you
staying at this hotel
i don't know you know it's like that guy
up in toronto right may police fan
who made the toronto stronger sign
and that the amount of outrage on that
it's like how old are people
you know
you're gonna get upset by that
don't make fun of our sign
you know and then you're looking at the
guy like what you think he actually
supports the terrorists
like how [ __ ] old are people
drives me up the [ __ ] wall i saw that
i actually i didn't see the sign
somebody tweeted to me that you know
that someone made that sign and it made
me laugh
because i knew what he meant
i know he doesn't support
the [ __ ] terrorists
you know
what happened was
that boston strong
came about because of those attacks and
then the bruins started wearing it and
after you see enough pictures
i'd like marshawn of those guys which
says boston strong it kind of also
morphs into we're saying that our team's
stronger than your team that's all it is
i'm not i'm not gonna lie to you the
ribbon was a little far all right
what the [ __ ]
can we just be adults
and stop getting can stop getting
[ __ ] outraged oh i'm saying we i
gotta stop doing that that's the most
annoying thing ever
can a number of you become adults
okay and stop having outrage over
absolute [ __ ] [ __ ]
and maybe have it about something that
affects your [ __ ] life
like these banker [ __ ]
you know the ones you get you check to
every every week who are robbing you
[ __ ] blind can you have outrage about
that how about that
instead of a [ __ ] sign or pink socks
you know you're not wearing pink
you don't support ah just go [ __ ]
yourself
sorry
jesus where the hell did that all come
from
you know why because it's may 13th
and then seven seven's lucky can
somebody on for the love of [ __ ] god
tell me why seven's lucky and don't even
tell me because it wins on the first
roll and craps because after that if you
don't roll it then
you you [ __ ] crap out on it more time
than than not
why is seven lucky because of bert jones
what the [ __ ] never was joe teisman
wasn't he number seven
now he got his leg [ __ ] shattered
dude got it [ __ ] shattered
joe theismann with that [ __ ]
that one goddamn
bar across you know
i don't know all right it's not an
unlucky day and if friday the 13th
bad things come in threes
how old are you
when are you gonna [ __ ] grow up
and grab this steering wheel
you know
and just stop letting the car float
around
and you're living your whole life
through fate
you know i [ __ ] hate when people
even people are going for something and
they don't get it and then they just oh
you know i guess it wasn't meant to be
it wasn't meant to be he just [ __ ]
you know
you just [ __ ] throw it up in the air
like a bunch of [ __ ] confetti that's
your life
how about
if you didn't [ __ ] it up it wouldn't
would have been uh meant to be you know
i know what the [ __ ] i'm talking about
here
um anyways i am in boston massachusetts
right now and um i'm gonna go to the
game tonight game seven the only happy
thing about that it's gone seven games
um but i've learned to be
i've learned that this is how the bruins
do it this year
they take the first two periods off and
then they decide to start playing
oh no no no earlier this year they
played the first two periods they'd
scored two goals
and then
the other team would gradually tie it up
and then we'd lose in overtime it's been
one of the most frustrating years as a
fan
i still love him i still support him but
um
you
know
i i [ __ ] knew it
i'm sound like versey but i called it
after game four
i know yesterday i tweeted that thing
you know i was trying to help give the
bruins something positive where i said
the toronto
was going to say blue jaysor leafs fall
but if you really look at my tweet
after game four yeah four we went up
three games to one where i said this
series isn't over i don't want to go
back to toronto
toronto doesn't deserve to be down three
games to one and i got all that [ __ ]
from [ __ ] bruins fans do you know
what i'm talking about now
why were you ignoring that that series
couldn't have easily been two to two if
not three one the other way
you know and not to take anything away
from toronto but when you don't [ __ ]
show up ready to play
in the in the playoff playoffs
you know what do you think is going to
happen
if you don't [ __ ] turn it up a notch
until the final 10 minutes of the game
and what [ __ ] kills me is whenever
they do that then they go out and they
score a goal
i don't know what it is
i love the bruins too much to ever say
that i don't think that they have what
it takes this year
but um
that's what they keep doing
you know i feel like toronto has played
more consistently
they [ __ ] the bed game one without a
doubt
but uh
other than that they played great game
two
game three we kind of got him but they
didn't play bad and game four was a
[ __ ] classic
and then i don't know what we've been
doing the last two games just skating
around like we're out there the ice
capades like oh maybe this is the game
we can close them up
so um
but i have faith i think we're going to
do it tonight i think they're actually
going to [ __ ] maybe come out with the
same intensity that they had in the
final 10 minutes of the last two games i
hope they do or else we're going to lose
and you know what we're going to we're
going to 100 deserve it
and uh
i don't hate toronto where they're fans
there's always a couple of kanti people
on twitter but i in general i like them
and i actually went to a bruins toronto
game a few years ago i liked them up
there and uh congratulations and thank
you to the ottawa senators
for knocking out the hated habs
i actually watched the replay of the
game wanting to totally enjoy watching
all the canadian fans filing out of the
building and you know what they didn't
some of them did but there's always fair
weather fans but i got to tell you i
actually was impressed like 80 to 85
percent of the habs fans stayed there
and in the end even though they were
losing like six to one they all got up
gave their team a standing ovation
saying that stupid oleo leo lay song and
i was like you know what those are
awesome fans you know
in toronto if you lose tonight
i want to tell you
you have to blame the canadians
the canadian fans
all right
because you guys were already in a bad
way until they put that [ __ ] patrick
walk hex on all of canada
what they did to arguably the greatest
goaltender who ever played the game
the way they [ __ ] humiliated him
and they haven't learned a thing they
haven't learned a thing they still do
that sarcastic chair when their [ __ ]
goaltender's getting shelled
they're just always
gonna be
these [ __ ] croissant-eating [ __ ]
spoiled [ __ ] brats
the most spoiled fans i've ever seen in
my [ __ ] life the way that they treat
their own players
is is
horrific
all right what they did to patrick watt
not only [ __ ] them
for god knows how long put a hex on
their team what they did was so
disrespectful to the game of hockey that
was created in canada not only have the
montreal canadiens never won another cup
since that moment no other team in
canada has won it
look at the vancouver canucks they were
up two games to none
they had the bruins right where they
wanted them and then what
burroughs got [ __ ] possessed decides
to bite who the [ __ ] did he bite on the
bruins
they woke up the bear
and they proceeded to lose
four
of the next five games
and lord stanley stayed down in the
lower 48. sorry sorry for all the hockey
talk to all the ladies out there and for
all the guys out there who don't watch
[ __ ] hockey because you'd rather
watch what baseball is that would you
rather watch
great day for a ball game it's uh zero
zero here the uh fourth inning
uh lovely mother's day afternoon there's
a ball outside and uh
this is the 79th pitch of this at bat
i'll tell you he's having a heck of a
bat
there's a groud ball the second base
flips it open at first
two outs
here the fourth inning
i'll tell you when you look at this
boston skyline you know it's just
it's just really wonderful i like uh
some of my favorite buildings to stare
at while i watch this game that's called
a sport
um
i'm sorry i just can't i cannot get into
[ __ ] baseball
i tried watching the red i've watched
the red sox in so long like i didn't
even i
poppy's the only guy left on the team
that i even know it's just been so
[ __ ] long since i watched
you know
it's just everybody was testing positive
for steroids and i was just like look
either legalize them or get them out of
the goddamn game
all right
but stop telling me
getting me all excited about [ __ ] and
then four years later telling me it
didn't really count
you know what i mean i still love
baseball but uh
i don't know how do i watch that when
playoff hockey's going on you know what
i mean how about those la kings
huh
now right there that's that's as a
sports fan that's what i like to see
they go down two games to none and then
they just kind of look around like oh
are we gonna stop [ __ ] around here
and then they just immediately turn it
on that's very impressive considering
they won the cup last year and usually
you have the little hang over there
so uh all right i'm done [ __ ] yapping
about hockey let's let's get on with the
podcast here um so i'm gonna go to the
game here tonight now i'm still talking
about hockey and i got a good feeling
that we're actually gonna try and uh
we're actually gonna try tonight
that's what i would just like at this
point if we could just maybe try
for [ __ ] three periods
actually play up to our potential we
still might not win but can we go down
swinging
can we just [ __ ] do that
um anyways here's something that
somebody sent me
um
they're working on this microchip that
will save your memory
scientists set to implant device to
preserve experiences into brains
a group of u.s researchers believe that
a microchip
that will help create memories
in damaged brains could be implemented
into human volunteers in the next two
years
the scientists from the university of
southern california wake forest
university and others have been looking
into the what is that the hippocampus
the part of the brain
that is vital in forming long-term
memories
for around a decade
okay they've been doing this so this is
this is their way in
so these wonderful researchers at usc
and wake forest
as always
their hearts are in the right place
but what kills me is it's like as
they're creating this thing i always
wondered do they sit around
when they create something like this
and did they ever go
good lord what if this falls into the
wrong hands
what if somebody like dick cheney or
donald rumsfeld
or any one of those other guys that
looks like they don't even have a
[ __ ] heartbeat what if it falls into
their hands what are they gonna do with
this [ __ ]
i'm telling you
all going to be i'm we're i i might not
be microchipped in my lifetime but i
will tell you this at some point in my
lifetime
and i figure they're going to do it
through some sort of like
they're gonna scare the [ __ ] out of
people
that their babies are gonna get
kidnapped
all right
and that what they're gonna do is
eventually
they're gonna pass a law
that all babies born from this day on
for their own
safety and their own protection will be
microchipped
all right it's gonna creep out a guy
like me who isn't microchipped but i'm
gonna die off and then what's going to
happen is just people from day one are
going to have a microchip in them and
they're not going to question it
and occasionally somebody will question
it and then they'll just be like what
are you a [ __ ] conspiracy theorist
do you realize that if every human being
was microchipped do you realize
the ability to revolt
how limited it is if you ever were to be
suddenly under an oppressive power
if everybody was microchipped you know
and this is what kills me is i know you
this most of you are rolling your eyes
going this sounds like crazy talk
you know why because you would never do
something like that
you know
i don't [ __ ] know anyways let's get
into some advertising that's a nice
setup
it's a nice setup from advertising all
right everybody right out of the gate
all right i've been telling you this for
years you don't have to go to the post
office anymore there's nothing okay
stamps.com here we go there's nothing
instant about getting postage from the
post office
driving there parking there it's a waste
of time so use stamps.com instead
instantly get postage for any letter or
package right from your desk stamps.com
is so quick and easy to use that even a
[ __ ] like me can use it
i send out all my dvds every last one of
them to all my stand-up gigs
and i do it whenever i want two in the
morning two in the afternoon
while i'm eating cereal while i'm not
eating cereal buy and print official us
postage using your own computer and
printer stamps.com will send you a
digital scale that automatically
calculates the exact post that you need
they'll even help you decide the best
class of mail based on your needs no
guesswork plus it's convenient take care
of your mailing and shipping whenever
you need to 24 7 right from your desk
you'll never have to go to the post
office again
just breathe that in everybody isn't
that wonderful
um endorsement here we go i use stamps i
already did that i already told them i
did it when am i going to say it again
uh right now use my last name burp
b-u-r-r for this special offer no risk
trial plus a hundred and ten dollar
bonus awful that offer that that
includes a digital scale and up to fifty
five dollars free postage sorry about
saying bonus awful that was this
freudian slip when i was thinking about
this read
do it right now don't wait go to
stamps.com before you do anything else
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page and type in bur b you are
that stamps.com enter bur
all right one more here strap yourselves
in personal capital
personal capital two things suck about
managing your money it's hard to keep
track of
you got stocks bonds 401k ira bank
accounts etc all on different sites with
their own username and password
then you pay someone to management
and you uh to manage it and you're
probably paying too much
that's why you got to go to personal
capital it takes under a minute to set
up just go to the podcast page on
billboard.com and click on personal
capital banner
on the personal capital banner excuse me
then you can see your whole net worth
and how each asset is performing
on one screen on your computer or
through their app on your phone or
tablet
tablet what the hell's a tablet
is that like an ipad sounds very
biblical
just pictured myself in a long robe with
a white beard holding my tablet
then it shows you how much you're paying
money managers and brokers and fees and
how much you can reduce those fees and
even gives you specific areas where you
can improve your investment strategy
basically what what should have been
done all the entire time
is now finally being done
all right this thing is really as a
really smart way to make your uh your
money grow quicker it's run by a former
ceo of paypal and it's totally free
totally free everybody
to sign up for free go to the podcast
page on billboard.com and click on the
personal capital banner
there you are all right
so anyways back to the damn podcast here
um as mentioned before i'm here in
boston and uh
you know what i didn't realize that i
missed
i i missed the chinese food here in
boston
all right and i ate so much of that [ __ ]
i left boston massachusetts in 1995
in 1995
and uh
at that point
i had gotten drunk so many times and
ended up in a chinese food restaurant
that to even smell chinese food
made me i almost got sick
all right
so now every time i've come back to
boston i've always avoided it
and i remember one night being at the
laugh factory talking to dane cook and
he told me he had just come back from
boston and the first thing he did was he
went out and got a poo poo platter
and ate all this [ __ ] chinese food
and i almost got sick as i was listening
to him chicken fingers crab rangoon all
this east coast chinese i was so [ __ ]
sick of it
and i and i was actually laughing to
myself as he was telling me the story
like thinking to myself that this guy
must really love chinese food
you know
and then i realized that he doesn't
drink like me so he probably didn't od
on it like an [ __ ] at three in the
morning for 20 years straight like i did
not 20 years more like eight but it was
a but it felt like 20.
you know so anyways
the other night
um
i had an amazing night
i went to my alma mater
and uh old billy redface got himself an
award
at
uh
it was a very overwhelming night
actually i couldn't even get through my
friggin speech i had to like cut it
short because i was getting all
emotional like a little
little [ __ ] school girl there
um
what i meant to say that night by the
way for anybody was there was that
emerson college it really changed my
life
because i was absolutely
flailing
in my life
at that point
i was a 22 year old
i just finished my freshman year
of college
at 22 and i didn't take any time off
i was going to college
from the time i graduated until the time
i was 22.
all right basically three and a half
four years at that point
um and i had just finished
my freshman year i was a convicted drunk
driver i had a giant orange afro i
didn't have any i had nothing going on
and uh i transferred to emerson college
and then immediately i don't know i i
those kids were the same kind of weird
that i was
some more weird some less weird but in
general
and i got there with this the sole
purpose of getting over the fear
of standing in front of a crowd
so every class basically at that school
you could somehow ham it up and get out
in front of the class
and that's what i did and i got involved
in radio because i felt like if i i
could just i could talk on a mic two
people that i couldn't see
and uh
i don't know within a year there was a
talent contest the next thing you know
i'm doing stand-up comedy so uh that's
what i wanted to say
so thank you to emerson college and
thank you for giving me the award was
unreal
unreal night stephen wright former
emerson uh
student actually presented the award
said a bunch of nice things and it was
uh was it was
too much
too much
i got to tell you that so anyway so
later on that night
um
no i was literally i got to go back to
that i was literally blown away
you know this is a guy that i saw
make johnny carson
like laugh like i'd never seen him laugh
like you could tell that he knew that he
this just wasn't another comic that this
was one of those guys that comes along
once every 15 20
25 years
and um to have him present in the water
was just it was amazing so
definitely a big thanks to him
so anyway so later on that night i hook
up with some of my family i'm having a
couple of beers
and i you know and it's like donuts you
know it's two in the morning
i'm in the outskirts of boston
everybody's getting hungry there's only
one [ __ ] thing left to do let's go
get some chinese food and i'm thinking i
don't want to get chinese i didn't think
really think one way or the other
and we sat down at this place the
[ __ ] tahiti
out in debt of massachusetts
and sat down
we got crab rangoon
we got that those gelatinous [ __ ]
ribs i got some egg rolls some fried
rice and i have to tell you it was
[ __ ]
delicious
the greatest things i've had the
greatest meals i've had since i can
remember
and i know it all went straight to my
artery and it's still sitting in there
and i'm amazed that i don't have chest
pains right now
um
i i i
i'm smart enough to not go get it again
but that's how good it was because then
i'll od on it again but i'm i'm [ __ ]
pissed that i didn't get chicken chicken
fingers are [ __ ] gross so
it's basically
it looks like uh
like to can be mutumbo's finger
except lighter
but just as long you remember in living
color when they used to make fun of
arsenio putting that one finger in the
air and they made it like extra long
that's the shape of it i don't know what
part of the chicken is shaped like that
that was the big joke chickens don't
have fingers what the [ __ ] is this
it's basically like nine million
chickens they all mash together and then
they just start chopping them up in the
shape of a giant [ __ ] index finger
then they bread the [ __ ] and they deep
fry it then they give you some duck
sauce and then you eat it at 2 30 in the
morning and it goes right to you [ __ ]
hot
um
so anyways
i don't even know what the point of that
story is was that mean am i literally
giving a shout out to food
at this point
why not anyways oh by the way
i'm doing i'm going to be in las vegas
this this weekend coming up
at the mirage casino i think there are a
couple of tickets left
this is my big
you know
first time i've ever headlined las vegas
um
at one of the major casinos
i've done some of the smaller ones but
this is the first time so i feel like
this is my first official one so uh
i'm basically going to be coming out on
stage the way the bruins play in the
final 10 minutes of a playoff game
except i'm going gonna do it from the
beginning
to the end hopefully hopefully i don't
have a letdown
um so anyways whoever's gonna be out
there i hope to see you guys
and with that
with that let's get to uh
let's get to some uh let's get to some
emails for this week
uh been some phenomenal emails over the
last couple of weeks and i think this
week's gonna be no different so let's
delve in
shall we
um oh before i do that [ __ ] by the way
somebody told me about i think i was on
the bob and tom show and they told me
about this daily mail website and it's
one of the most depressing websites i've
ever been to in my life
terror at the mother's day parade this
is this is the headlines horrific moment
three gunman opened fire in broad
daylight during street festival leaving
19 people including two young children
injured
uh judge bans girl 14 from every school
in county
after she films herself mercilessly
beating another student as a gang of 30
classmates watch
so they're already depressing you and
then they try to [ __ ] lighten it up
by a little bit by saying a braless
jennifer aniston is steered around by
justin i don't know who justin is i
guess that that's her boyfriend but even
then it's kind of negative
he's steering her around like what
jennifer can't go where she i want to go
into amber crummy get over here [ __ ]
um
i got a couple are these the worst
passengers of all time bloggers exposed
the rudest most disgusting commuters in
new york
one of them's just a girl eating food
i don't think that that's bad
another one's a [ __ ] out-of-shape
transvestite or a cross-dresser with his
[ __ ] sports bra on his big belly
hanging out
somebody doing a split
i don't know look at richard nixon's
[ __ ]
grandson in eris
christ look at the [ __ ] gigantic rack
on her you know what is funny though the
church of scientology got busted for
photoshop and then more people are at an
event in portland to make it seem like a
huge crowd when in reality only 750
people were there or
the catholic church
is [ __ ] trying to to to ruin
scientology and claiming that they
photoshopped people in
when they didn't
you know kind of like how the nfl tried
to stop the afl
who knows
but i can tell you what you can take
both those religions and toss them in
the [ __ ] trash
you know
how old are you people
nobody knows what's out there after you
die
all right
stop getting up early on sunday there's
really no point to it sleep in
um real age
what's up bill this is uh so and so in
such and such city
me and my fiance are getting married
soon and her [ __ ] wookie of a mother
or the rest of her family still don't
know how old i am
well that's great sir that's a great way
to start a relationship for the rest of
your life
she is 23 and i'm 37.
we've been making each other come for
three years now
any advice on how to break this info to
these [ __ ]
yeah i have some advice why don't you
call off the [ __ ] marriage
why don't you do that
all right
considering this is the woman that you
love
and the way you describe your
relationship is that they make each
other come for the last three years
you're describing the mother of this
woman you allegedly love as a [ __ ]
wookie
um
yeah
but considering she's probably going to
age like her i guess she's eventually
going to turn into a wookie too
i don't know dude you don't sound like
you're mature enough
but you could also just
be trying to make me laugh
so i have no idea
wow it's a little late for this sir
you know this is actually real because i
went to a wedding this is why i'm back
here in boston i actually went to a
wedding one of the great weddings i
haven't isn't is there anything [ __ ]
better than going to a wedding
where the two people look like they
should be getting married you just see
it
you feel the spark between the two of
them there's nothing better
you combine that with great food and an
open bar and a great live band i'll tell
you you got yourself a hell of an
evening
i went to an awesome wedding
this weekend me and the lovely nia we
had a great time
and uh now i gotta read this [ __ ]
um any advice on how to break this info
to these [ __ ]
yeah i'd write a poem
i'd figure out what rhymes with 37
maybe you could sing it to him
i love your daughter
when i'm with her it's heaven
oh by the way i got great pubes
cause i'm 37
yeah sorry about that you [ __ ] wookie
how about that
why don't you do something like that i
don't know how to do that sir i've never
been involved in a lie that deep
that's that's some deep [ __ ] there sir
listen you you're going to have to
[ __ ] tell them soon or the only way
out of this is there's going to be a
couple of body bags
all right what's wrong with you
why didn't you tell them out of the gate
you know why because you feel like a
creep don't you sir
you feel like a creep
you know
when you make references to britney
spears and she doesn't even know who
that is that's actually me you know the
other night i used that reference
because i needed a reference for a
floozy and i threw out britney spears
and like this younger crowd just sat
there staring at me and i actually did
the math in my head and i had to be like
wait a minute britney spears
is now
a 31 32 year old divorced mother of two
and i was just like jesus christ i'm
[ __ ] old
who is the floozy reference of the
moment
you know you can't even say lady gaga at
this point she's so [ __ ] old now she
had to get a hip replacement
you know like your grandmother
taylor swift right maybe it's her
taylor swift looks like one of those
cats that just [ __ ] creeps you out
you know that voodoo [ __ ] like they sit
on your chest and they suck the soul out
of you
she is that like you could never snuggle
with her
and not feel that she was slowly killing
you you know do you think she sleeps in
a pod
doesn't she have like that
that webbed toe look about her that's
really mean but i don't know i saw this
thing on her 60 minutes one time and the
crowd was cheering and she looked up in
the upper deck and she just did the
creepiest look to the upper deck
deck and just went
oh my
god like really like
this totally phony like i can't believe
you guys are cheering at me like that
i don't know
oh christ i don't even know what i'm
saying anymore
uh past this prime
prime question mark
hello william i need some advice by the
way you guys you all realize i'm a [ __ ]
right i flunked everything in high
school
okay
this is on you if you take my advice and
it doesn't work you know
you should go talk to somebody who
actually professionally gives out advice
and part of your therapy session should
be why you take advice from someone who
doesn't know what the [ __ ] he's talking
about
oh bill shut up and just read it okay
all right hi bill i need some advice my
fiance and i used to have in an insane
sex life two to three times a day crazy
marathon sex sessions we used to
celebrate
sexter day
what does that mean
what is that when you reminisce about
how much you [ __ ] yesterday
ah you kids i don't know what you're
talking about
sexter day
boo boo oh my [ __ ] seems so far away
i put it in your ass and not cause i'm
gay i just [ __ ] your vag
enough [ __ ] times ooh
your [ __ ] vag you know it's like i
woke up and the lyrics just came to me
to the point i thought did someone else
talk about this somebody else already
write this song
not for lack of trying on my part i love
giving him blow jobs oh what a champ
she says she loves giving [ __ ]
and now he always says
not right now when i try
uh we welcomed our first baby six months
ago
i am now in better shape than i was
before i got pregnant
i do yoga and run every day and feel
sexier than ever
i am 22 and he is 40.
has he passed his prime he's been
stressed out lately does that keep men
from getting it up he was my first so
the only thing
i know about male sexuality is what i
know about him
usually he can't keep his hands off me
help bill it's hard not to take this
personally
thank you well aren't you a sweetheart
um you like giving blow jobs and you're
very polite and you know how to write a
letter
god damn it you're a keeper
and you were virgin at 22 you saved
yourself and here this guy comes along
the grizzled vet in the final year of a
three-year contract
you know
once you sign the contract he stops
producing
well i for one i feel for you
um
did he watch you give birth
you know that that that new thing that
they do over the last 20 30 years back
in the day you should just stand out in
the waiting room with the big stogie
just stand out how's she doing
yeah is there blood pressure dropping
oh she passed away on the table ah
[ __ ] 120 cigars out the window
you used to stand out there in the
waiting room
you know and you let the doctors be
doctors
i don't understand why the guy has to be
in there i i don't this is a big
[ __ ]
debate between me and the lovely nia
like i don't understand why this why you
have to [ __ ] be in there you know
when i go down to minus muffler do i
[ __ ] stand underneath it is he
sitting there and the sparks are flying
i don't know how to weld
you know yeah you got a busted aspirated
tube i don't know where that is i don't
know what it is
why am i there
you know
i should be out in the [ __ ] waiting
room so anyways did he stand there and
then just watch something alive come out
of your vagina maybe it's it's kind of
because i hear that guys have like maybe
performance issues after that
you know
there's a whole bunch of things that
could be going on here so i don't want
to put too many
how are you guys doing financially
how is his job security
you know does he spend a lot of money
this is the other shoe about ready to
drop are you one of those
one of those couples
that i see on those reality shows
you know does he wear like a lot of
t-shirts or like button-down shirts that
have a lot of designs on them
a lot of drawing
you know
does he fake tan is he one of those guys
because if he's one of those guys then i
would guess that you're actually broke
and have been broke for eight months and
he doesn't know how to tell you
um but if he's a regular guy
all right i'm joking around too much
about this this is actually a serious
thing all right help me build it's hard
not to take this personally
um i would bring it up to him
you got to sit down and uh
hopefully
he's not a walled off emotional psycho
like most guys
if you bring it up
and hopefully you can bring it up to him
without him getting mad
but um that's what i would do
i'd bring it up and just be like hey uh
you know you haven't been banging me
lately and uh i know i'm looking pretty
good and used to it all the time what's
what's the deal
you know
just that's the essence of it just
stretch that out into about eight
minutes and say a lot of loving things
um
do that thing where you put your hand on
the you know the women they put their
hand on your their forearm on the dude's
forearm and they and they move you move
your thumb side to side
and just be like hey
how come we're not [ __ ] anymore i
don't know how to do it
that's what i would do i think you need
to talk to him rather than me uh i would
not take it personally
you know you're you're a [ __ ] champ
you love giving blow jobs
you're in the prime of your life you had
a kid what did you do you got yourself
right back in shape you're in the best
shape of your life it's not on you so i
wouldn't take it personally so there's
obviously something going on with him
and you love the guy so try to help him
bring it out
you know
no jesus all right there you go there's
that
i hope that helped
i don't [ __ ] know let's let's take a
break from my ignorant
my ignorant [ __ ] advice
to talk to you about this everybody
e-voice e-voice is the reason you're
gonna make more money in 2013.
well actually it's your great idea
combined with e-voice alrighty voice
don't take all the credit
you know
all right when your customers call
you'll have your own toll-free number
professional greeting dial by name
directory and more you'll sound more
like a fortune 500 company and you'll
blow away your competitors e-voice lets
you give out one number that rings
wherever you are the beach the bar
doesn't matter you'll sound like you're
at the office
you gotta go to evoice.com and use the
promo code bill evois even takes all
your voicemails transcribes them and
sends them to you instantly as a text or
email so you can check your voicemails
before the meeting ends not to leave and
look rude you know you won't even look
rude evoice is only 10 bucks a month 10
bucks a month so your new little company
can sound like a fortune 5 com 500
company it's an absolute bargain right
now listeners to my podcast get a free
trial of e-voice for 30 days
stop what you're doing right now hit
pause set up your e-voice trial and see
what i'm talking about it's a great way
to support my podcast and it's an easy
way to make money this year go to
evoice.com promo code bill that's evoice
dot com promo code bill or just go to
the podcast page on billboard.com and
click on the e-voice banner ad right now
okay
now you know when i bring this stuff up
you know
you know that father's day is coming up
i was speaking of which yesterday i took
my mother out for an ice cream for
mother's day
and i got up to the window
and i realized i didn't have any money
and then she had to pay for it
i did hit an atm on the way home but it
really kind of killed
a lot of the vibe
um
but anyways i was happy to be home for
mother's day so after mother's day what
comes next everybody memorial day
what comes after that flag day what
comes after today
father's day
actually i think father's day is before
flag day and what do i sell you every
year the man great system
the man great system everybody this
father's day
think the man great
what is the man great you ask
what is the man great you think of as
you rub your chin
this is what they are these are actually
great i wish they had these when i was a
kid when i was growing up on my little
hibachi
they're 100 percent made in america made
in america cast iron grilling grates
that are revolutionizing the way people
grill heavy duty grilling grates deliver
exactly what you need to achieve that
perfect steakhouse flavor chicken
steak or veggies will never have tasted
so good no more flare-ups no more dry
meat guaranteed name one of 2012's best
grilling accessories by men's health
magazine basically what they are is you
know when you buy
you buy some cheap ass grill
and they give you those little aluminum
you know that grilling grate this gives
you the big steel ones
just like at the steak house
so it's basically like you went out you
bought some hatchback with the
four-cylinder
all right the man-grade system make
allows you the ability to rip that
four-cylinder out of the car and put a
good old-fashioned american v8 on top
it's phenomenal
uh man greats are perfect the perfect
gift for father's day come on every man
loves to grill go to man great dot com
and enter the coupon code burr p-u-r-r
for their 1999 father's day special or
click the man great banner on the show
website
uh 100 percent made in america 100 cast
iron 100
steakhouse quality in your backyard all
right
remember each monday morning podcast
order comes with a heavy duty grilling
brush again that's the man great grill
enhancement system order today
man great dot com
and at the the coupon code burr at the
checkout all right there you have it so
back to the back to the questions
back to the questions here where the
hell am i
all right
can we find it there we go
all right this one's titled oh geez
uh
dear billy goat [ __ ] face
there's a new one
there's a new one
i am a 23 year old man from
paducah kentucky
now why would you tell me that i didn't
want to read that there's probably 18
people in your
your town right
needless to say there isn't much to do
about five months ago i met a girl who
was two years younger than me
and moved into town from [ __ ] east
congo manga
uh we hit it off almost instantly it was
great
you know what i'm gonna have somebody
bleep out this city
all right i gotta bleep out the city in
the state
he goes we hit it off almost instantly
it was great she is beautiful educated
and has a great ass
sorry little al pacino for you
we took things slow
and i found that to be something unique
in today's time
most girls give it up within a day or
two but she wanted to take things slow
and i appreciated that i found myself
falling head over heels for this girl i
hadn't been with anyone in over two
years and i felt that it if she was
wait and i felt as if she was a sign
that maybe there was a bit of hope in
this world to be happy
and she communicated with me that she
felt the same way
okay so
about two weeks ago we went out to a bar
and we had some drinks played some pool
and had a great time and ended up
getting a little frisky with each other
i drove her home totally expecting that
tonight would be the night i was going
to bang this beautiful woman when we
reached the driveway we started making
out in the car
and
asked if she wanted to come in she got
real quiet and said under her breath yes
but
and of course i said but what and that's
when she told me
she is a transsexual
i literally yelled
i was so shocked by what i heard i could
hardly keep myself together and i told
her him whatever that i wasn't going to
go upstairs with her and i would call
her tomorrow
and she got out of the car crying and
said i was born this way
like some lady gaga [ __ ]
wait a minute trans what is what is what
is transsexual like a hermaphrodite
wait a second
ah jesus bill you you're too [ __ ]
dumb why do you guys why do you guys
write me
is this is this the fun
is this the fun part of it
just finding out how [ __ ] dumb i am
transsexual this is hilarious now i have
this on my search and engine transsexual
and neo will use my computer and look up
like transcontinental and transsexuals
bill is there something we need to talk
about
uh
transsexual here we go a person
who's undergone a sex change operation
a person whose sexual identification
is entirely with the opposite sex
all right well that just made me even
more confused
so if you had an operation how are you
born this way
or she's or the person saying i just
identified with being a female
oh i said okay so they had a set so the
dude had a sex change
operation okay
he goes i haven't spoke to her
since
it's s-i-n-c-e dot
s-e-n-c-s-e um
that night
besides a few text messages she's going
on about how much she loves me and she
is sorry she didn't tell me sooner it's
even gone as far as me having to turn
off my phone because she won't stop
calling i've never been pursued like
this before
what do i do
part of me actually feels bad but i
can't see myself banging an ass every
night well my sweaty balls slap against
her sweaty balls now wait a minute i
thought the person had the operation
don't they remove that
you know i don't [ __ ] know regardless
of how gay this may sound i still think
she is incredibly hot
i knew it was too good to be true
should i tell her that i'm just not
interested anymore and completely cut
her off or should i be your friend
or should i go banger ass
it's weird
the thought of banging her ass excites
me
but the thought of her junk swinging
around makes me want to throw up just
thinking about it
thanks bill and come do a show in such
and such state sometime you [ __ ]
um
what should you do um
i don't know
i honestly don't know
what's funny is
you're literally
just like you're mentally where she is
sexually
you know
i don't know like
you gotta you gotta you it's like you're
standing on the state line and you got a
foot in either state just like her
you know
so
i think your your emotions are normal
and i hate when [ __ ] people get
offended by this [ __ ]
and they go dead dead [ __ ] you you
know they get all offended like that
dude is now a woman
it's like no that is a dude
that [ __ ] uh
is a different kind of dude now
you know it's that's not a woman
it's still a dude
it's just a different kind of dude you
know what it's like you ever see when
somebody does uh
buys an old car and they take all the
chrome off it they want that nice clean
look yeah that's what they do to their
their their their crotch
you know that's a dude that took the
chrome off
you know
i don't know what to tell you
other than uh
i i don't i don't know do do like that
[ __ ]
i don't i don't know dude do do whatever
the [ __ ] you want to do
is what i i would say
let me go back and read what you said
should i tell i'm not just anymore
completely cut off
[Music]
all right part of me actually feels bad
because i can see myself
because i can't see myself banging an
ass every night while my sweaty balls
slap against her sweat balls
well if it makes you feel better i don't
think the balls are there anymore
although
they might have kept them like a hood
ornament i have no idea
oh jesus
i really am a [ __ ]
regardless of how gay this may sound i
still think she's incredibly hot
you know why don't you just split the
difference and get a [ __ ] i don't
know what to tell you
that's so funny i knew it was too good
to be true this poor bastard
uh
i i would say this i'd say you'd want to
sit on that decision don't be like the
baltimore colts
in the 1983 draft did you guys just
watch that 30 for 30 where they
immediately walked up two seconds in and
they selected john elway
you know rather than [ __ ] waiting the
full two minutes or whatever to see if
anybody gave him an offer and then they
ended up with nothing i i would i'd sit
on this one for a minute
um
and i think that this person's actually
pursuing you
the way that they are because they're in
a desperate situation
which is uh the whole thing is in
reality the whole thing is unfortunate
you know people should be able to be who
they are you should be able to like who
you like and that person should be able
to from
day one say that they're transsexual
without getting judged the reason why
they didn't say it was because they were
worried about this [ __ ] moment here
which once again is another sad
depressing thing
about humanity
um i would say follow your heart sir
you know
and not your balls
if you really want to find love
there you go balls in your court
no pun intended
all right advice for a young
lady
hey billington
um very very original once this this
this week people coming up with
different ways to butcher my name i'm
i'm enjoying these
i am in need of some advice for a young
lady i love that some women are actually
piping in despite the fact how much i
talk about hockey on this podcast
what do you think women don't like
hockey
yes this is what i'm saying
um i'm an 18 year old high school senior
entering my freshman year of college
i got into my dream school with the
scholarship ah do you know how bad i
wish that i did that
i wish i studied in high school anyways
and i'm moving out of my [ __ ] town
and everything finally finally seems to
be making up for all the [ __ ] that i
went through in high school
one of my really good friends
is going to the same university as i am
and we're renting an apartment together
however
my friend is an 18 year old straight guy
and i am a straight girl
uh-oh
the gender thing could add a whole
other level of difficulty on top of
adjusting to living with a new person in
a new city
away from everything i grew up around
we've been friends practically since we
were in diapers
we can talk jam out to 70s rock and
watch the chappelle show for hours and
we've never had issues with weirdness
before
but i do understand that college
introduces a lot of firsts and i'm not
going to lie
i'm a little nervous
that a few too many
oh having a few too many drinks during a
welcome weekend could lead to some
inappropriateness
weirder things where do things have
happened
um
i don't want to do anything to
jeopardize our nearly two-decade-long
friendship
so this kind of sounds like you're a
little attracted to this guy if you're
this worried that something's going to
happen or maybe you're you're 18 you're
going from your parents house to all of
a sudden living with the guy
maybe that's what it is
i'm going to guess that that's what it
is so anyway so my question
what tips do you have to stop anyone
from stepping over the line
with the male slash female roommate also
in general what tips do you have for
living with a roommate nia's opinion on
this would be epic
thanks and [ __ ] you
yeah that wasn't as great [ __ ] you last
week
um you know what maybe this wednesday i
will do another neolog and i'll read
this one but right now i'll just give
you my own
ignorant um
thought on it oh wait wait by the way
there's there's a ps to this everybody
there's an epilogue
just like the streets of san francisco
p.s might i add
that we've both been in various
relationships while friends
he often asked me for girl advice and i
asked him for guy advice he currently
has a girlfriend who i really like and
am friends with but they are breaking up
in june when she leaves to study abroad
i am currently single oh yeah you guys
are going to bang within [ __ ] eight
minutes
within eight minutes of your of your
your college career
um
all right so basically what you want to
do
you're not asking me should you or
should you not move in with this guy
you're gonna move in with this guy
so
uh what you're really saying is
basically how do i not [ __ ] this guy
well i can only do it from the male
perspective
which is what i would do is every
morning before i ever even walked out
into the living room was i would rub one
out
[Laughter]
to try to get that [ __ ]
you know
urge out of me
i think what you need to do is sit down
and talk with the guy
and just say listen we have a great
friendship and i don't want to ruin this
i know we're moving in together and
everything
but um
you know obviously we're going to be in
close quarters
you know sharing a bathroom and blah
blah blah blah
you know what you have to do you have to
lay down the law if that's what you
really want to do
but if you actually like this guy
like i think you might
um if you actually like him like him and
think you could actually did i just say
that if you like like i mean like like
him like him like him you know what i
mean
do you oh my god you guys
this could be the one
um
if you actually like this dude like that
then you should not move in with him
you should be in a separate apartment
and uh
that way if you start dating him
you don't immediately start by living
with one another
you know
that's just too far down the road
so what i would do if i was you is i
would sit down and talk to him
okay if you don't like this guy like
this and you really want to preserve
your friendship i would sit down and
have a talk to him or talk with them and
just say listen we cannot get drunk
and make out and and [ __ ] round
second base slide into third
we can't we can't do this [ __ ] all right
okay i'm telling you that right now
it's not happening
or whatever you got to say or if you
actually really like this guy
um
you got to tell him that
just say i think maybe i like you a
little more
than just friends i don't know i don't
know if this is just a little phase i
have no idea but if that's the case i
don't want to move in with you
you know
does that make sense you know what
you're right
there's gonna be a neolog this week
everybody [ __ ] this
i'm too dumb to answer this one this one
involves uh feelings that i don't
understand
all right so basically that's the
podcast for this week everybody um
once again i want to thank emerson
college
for giving me uh
that award and i want to thank stephen
wright for bringing me up and saying all
those nice things that he did
and uh
lastly but not leastly i'm gonna be uh
i'm gonna be at the mirage
casino in las vegas
this friday and saturday night then i
have a week off
and then i'm to do a nice tour through
jersey
uh maryland and uh baltimore i'll be at
the count basie theater on may 29th
with the teen idol sensation fresh off
his hit half hour special on comedy
central
um we're gonna be the count basie
theater in red bank new jersey
on june 30th
i will be in baltimore maryland sorry
don't have my the name of the theater in
front of me
on the
31st of june
of may
also known as june 1st
or is there a 34 there is the 31st may
31st i will be at eastern pennsylvania
and then on
june 1st
i'll be in atlantic city for two shows
so if you enter around that area
earlier
why don't you come on out you know come
out to some shows
and uh
hopefully i'll make you laugh your ash
off there
oh hey i gotta thank that crowd that
came out to the bottle rock uh bottle
rocket uh music festival i did a show at
four in the afternoon
while a band was playing right next door
and uh
i fought through that baseline that was
crushing all of my jokes and the level
of patience that that crowd showed was
was phenomenal
um all right so here we go that's the
podcast for this week go [ __ ] yourselves
don't take any [ __ ] from anybody
and uh in the last little bit of
advertising here
ladies and gentlemen
now that the show is over go sign up for
your free account with personal capital
so you can see all of your assets on one
screen pay less broker pay less in
broker fees and make all your
investments grow faster go to the
podcast page on billboard.com click on
the personal capital banners that's the
podcast page on billbird.com to click on
the personal capital banner and set up
your free account
also
now that the show is over ghosts also go
set up your free trial of e-voice so you
can start making more money go to
evoice.com and use your promo code bill
that's evoice.com promo code bill or
just go to the podcast page on
billboard.com and click the e-voice
banner right now all right have a
wonderful week
and uh i'll talk to you about vegas next
week all right go bruins
uh i have no hate towards toronto all
right
okay so i don't care when you send me
your obnoxious stuff i know you guys are
just excited because you haven't won
anything since 1967
you know which is rough does anybody
deserve that
no except for montreal canadian fans
alright see
you